even as one of only a handful of female
leads to carry a multi-million dollar
film franchise Kate Beckinsale still
feels unknown or at the very least
unappreciated Beckinsale is clearly
capable of delivering exceptional work
but in spite of what she's proven she
can do with the right script
opportunities to display her dramatic
chops have come far too infrequently
here are a few possible reasons why
Hollywood isn't offering Kate Beckinsale
more opportunities to shine pearl harbor
was a flop Beckinsale's potential big
break for American audiences ended up a
complete disaster after a standout
performance alongside Claire Danes in
1999 s brokedown Palace Beckinsale was
poised to really bust out as a leading
woman but the 2001 period blockbuster
Pearl Harbor which sought Beckinsale
playing the love interest to both Ben
Affleck and Josh Hartnett was almost
unanimously panned and the film
succeeded or had Beckinsale's
performance outshines the production
itself her career likely would have
taken a different path when leading to
more high-profile dramatic roles to make
matters worse after Pearl Harbor stunted
Beckinsale's growth as a viable lead in
a big-budget drama her next film all but
stopped her chances of working in the
romantic comedy genre no serendipity
here the 2001 rom-com serendipity
starring Beckinsale and John Cusack fell
flat with critics as well as the general
public by that point audiences had
suffered through or supported nearly two
decades of adorable yet hapless John
Cusack characters and by the turn of the
century the magic had started to wear
thin this is not to say either star was
particularly to blame for the film's
ultimate failure had serendipity been
better it might have been a perfect
pivot for Beckinsale alas it was not to
be
I have to give it all up now don't I
married to underworld after she was
tapped to play Celine in 2003's
underworld Beckinsale hit it off with
director Lynn Wiseman the two became
romantic and were married within two
years now more than a decade later
Wiseman and Beckinsale have worked on
multiple films together including
several in the underworld franchise
before their split in 2016 the
underworld films in particular cost
relatively little to produce do well at
the box office and have been quite
profitable but they aren't exactly
considered great cinema so while the
franchise has been rolling along
Beckinsale's career has suffered amongst
audiences directors and casting agents
she may be too closely associated with
Selene from underworld for them to
imagine her in any other role
imprisonment for a long time ageism
unfortunately Beckinsale is in a kind of
acting purgatory simultaneously too old
and too young to snatch up the most
desirable roles in the industry while
male leads can work well into their 50s
and 60s female leads are more often than
not left out of roles once they pass 40
as it stands Beckinsale has only one
credit in 2017 a drama called the only
living boy in new york alongside Pierce
Brosnan Jeff Bridges Cynthia Nixon and
Callum Turner in the movie Beckinsale's
character plays a mistress who begins an
affair with her lover's son working with
established talent and rising stars can
only be good for Beckinsale's continued
success in Hollywood but this doesn't
change the fact that she was chosen for
her role precisely because of her age
and her looks is that kind of vulgarity
in tidiness and kind of vulgar dementia
sexism in 2016 eken sail appeared on the
Graham Norton Show and revealed some
disparaging jabs director Michael Bay
made it her while he was on the press
junket for Pearl Harbor she said when we
were promoting the film Michael was
asked why he had chosen Ben Affleck and
Josh Hartnett and he said I worked with
Ben before and I loved him and josh is
so manly and a wonderful actor but they
apparently didn't share the same
thoughts about Beckinsale's ability she
continued then when he was asked about
me he'd
Kate wasn't so attractive that she would
alienate the female audience in a 2001
interview with Movieline Bay confirmed
his sentiments saying of why he cast
Beckinsale I didn't want someone who was
too beautiful women feel disturbed when
they see someone's too pretty regardless
of what Bay thinks of her appearance
Beckinsale has frequently been typecast
for her good looks and physique it's a
double-edged sword
whether in recent horror films like the
disappointments room or stonehearst
asylum or action flicks such as Total
Recall or the underworld series she's
not exactly doing Shakespeare in the
Park having played so many of these
types of characters over the past 20
plus years it's easy to see how she's
been overlooked or well everything else
yeah it's funny a turn to TV the average
cost to produce and market a wide
release film has skyrocketed over the
last 30 years and studios are no longer
willing to take risks on small budget
Indies or period dramas without major
star power unfortunately these are
precisely the types of films in which
Beckinsale has excelled with the big
screen less hospitable than ever it's
unsurprising that Beckinsale turned to
TV in 2018 she was announced as the star
of the limited run Amazon series the
widow about a woman drawn into a
dangerous quest after spotting her
supposedly late husband on the news
clearly an actress of Beckinsale's
talent and diverse resume is always just
the right script away from a comeback
time will tell if this is it thanks for
watching click the looper icon to
subscribe to our YouTube channel plus
check out all this cool stuff we know
you'll love to
[Music]